choosing the right database can feel
like a never-ending series of questions
structured or unstructured data scale or
consistency
relational or non-relational and wait
what about reliability stay tuned to see
how critter junction narrows the scope
of their search to get some much needed
answers
[Music]
when it comes time to choose the right
database for your application needs it's
all about trade-offs each database
product you'll run into has plenty of
differentiators and features
all designed to help you find the best
fit for your situation
which on one side is good but can also
lead to analysis paralysis
and this is where critter junction found
themselves when we met up with them
they were looking for a database for a
new web and mobile minigame
fortunately while looking at the cascade
of database options in google cloud
we help them match up each product to
their potential business needs
by focusing heavily on vertical versus
horizontal scaling
narrowing the scope of the search was
helpful for critter junction
and let them evaluate their options
through the lens of scale
first we took a look at sql or more
specifically cloud sql
a managed database offering for mysql
postgresql
and sql server a modern offering for a
tried and true classic
cloud sql is a great fit for any
application with loads of structured
data
that's looking for that sweet spot of
convenience configuration options
and performance the familiarity alone
could make this a helpful option for
critter junction
but again for this search we're focusing
on scaling
the best part is that cloud sql gives
you flexible control over scaling
and deployment it'll wait for you to
decide when
and how to grow with high availability
and replication built
in whether you need vertical scaling to
instances with higher cpu and memory
or adding read replicas to achieve
horizontal scaling
it's all up to you but since critter
junction's elite gamers couldn't handle
any downtime during resizing
and need to be able to fetch the latest
updates from each read replica
cloud sql wasn't the perfect choice and
once you reach a certain database size
or
4000 concurrent connections it might be
time to look at another option
so let's turn things up a notch when you
want the ability to go from small to
massive scale
spanner is your answer as a fully
managed relational database service
it handles nearly unlimited horizontal
scaling for you
it's also got automatic data sharding
and replication giving you that 99.99
uptime that your data admins and users
are so fond of
and while spanner is the backbone of
billion user services like gmail and
youtube
it might be a little too powerful for
critter junction's new mini-game alone
so let's reel it back in a bit to find a
better match
cloud firestore sits a little further
towards the opposite end of the spectrum
it'll handle horizontal scaling for you
but where spanner focuses on global
consistency availability and volume
firestore also focuses on developer
flexibility
specifically firestore can sync your
data directly with client applications
through real-time listeners and support
your hierarchical data structures with
real-time querying
and offline support firestore scales up
automatically with no downtime this lets
firestore handle
thousands of requests per second
millions of concurrent connections
automatic data replication and strong
consistency
this means firestore could offer the
flexibility that our critter junction
game devs need
while also giving them the scale for
their application size
sounds like a win for firestore while
firestore might be great to handle
things like configurations
friends lists and game services it's a
novice when it comes to big data
and for critter junctions analytics team
that's a big deal
as they need a separate database system
for their needs
but that's something we'll talk about in
the next episode when we dive deeper
into their full architecture
and explore spanner bigtable and memory
store as well
even though we've only scratched the
surface critter junction already has a
pretty solid starting point with
firestore for their mini-game
and is ready to start designing a larger
system to suit their needs
next time we'll show you how they grew
their architecture and database
solutions from here check out the links
below to learn more
and remember always be architecting
[Music]
you